I noticed too with the film that you
showed them all beautiful and dolled up
and in front of the camera and talking
with their customers but then you had
the audio which was much more sounded
like their real selves and some of the
painful things that they went through
how did you come to that decision to do
it like that well I think it was
important to kind of to show the the
disparity the difference there between
what their on-camera personas are and
what their off-camera personas are and
one of the you know it was it was an
immediate thing where when we first
realized we were gonna make the movie I
said to myself well how am I gonna get
through and get something that's not
what they're used to doing on camera
they're used to being on camera they're
used to
oh I see what's going on here they're
savvy so to kind of break that down a
little bit what I decided to do was
conduct no on-camera interviews so what
I would do is I would just I would sit
with the girls and wherever in their
house on their couch on their bed I
would get real close to them we'd get a
mic nice and close and we would just
talk for a couple hours and I would call
from from those interviews we put
together the audio that they're kind of
underlays over the film and we're
telling two different stories at once
but they really work well together and
you're hearing or something that's
really genuinely them you know I talked
about like it's it's their mid night
voice it's their rated-r voice it's
their just talking to a friend voice and
to be able to get that you know it
wasn't it wouldn't have been guaranteed
if we would have just slapped the camera
in front of them because they because
like I said they're very savvy to that
so instead we we focused on getting
through to their you know down to the
nitty gritty of their stories in a
really low stakes environment I think
that that helps bring out their real
voice and is that something that you
just saw over time because so much when
you when you go to someone's place -
they're in on mode and they want to
present the best PR aspect that they can
yeah you just see it too often when you
take out the camera and someone's like a
deer in the headlights and that that
puts the worst feeling over me as a
filmmaker I don't want to I don't want
to make someone feel like that let alone
you capture it you know for especially
for something like this we're trying to
get in there and and depict what they
normally do not what they're doing like
on camera for us so to make our presence
as little-known as possible is super
important
and yeah that that's really what fueled
that decision was was that seeing how
many times you try and fail to get
somebody to act like themselves on
camera and I had experimented with this
style with with doing the off-camera
interview in some commercials and I knew
it could be successful in storytelling
in us in a smaller way and my editor and
I just loved the challenge of doing it
for an entire film for a whole film that
that kind of is interview based but
never really showing an interview I dug
it that's excellent now Sean with this
technique of getting their audio and
just talking to them one on one without
the camera was this something that you
learned from another filmmaker or film
home I didn't go to film school I I've
had a lot of influences but not
necessarily specifically for for that
style it was something that like I said
I dabbled around with on commercials a
little bit and realized how it could
work and also just just kind of reading
the audience and seeing what's out there
currently and kind of just kind of going
against the tide a little bit well you
know with with just trying to do
something that maybe is a little bit
more engaging and not what you'd expect
so yeah not necessarily one filmmaker I
can point to in particular but uh lots
of guys over time for sure and women